déboutée mais toujours aussi déterminée
avec leurs avocats et le responsable cgt
jacques rambur les ex salariés d'alstom
puiseront tous les recours envisagerons
toutes les possibilités pour que leur
préjudice d'anxiété soit enfin reconnue
il est vrai que lille est au courant
tout le monde est un peu au courant des
grands patrons les tout le monde savait
de camions mais personne n'a rien dit
voilà donc une fois qu'ils en soient
atteints b alors c'est le gouvernement
c'est la politique qui qui a fait que
alstom
condamné en février dernier la cour de
cassation déboute les plaignants
confirmant ainsi le jugement de la cour
d'appel de besançon
la suite logique aurait été de se
tourner vers la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme mais pour m chami
s'est perdue d'avancé
il propose donc une nouvelle stratégie
engagé une procédure devant le tribunal
administratif pour faire condamner
l'état français la responsabilité de
l'état français est incontestable il
devait assurer ma sécurité il devait
mettre en place des réglementations au
vu des connaissances de l'époque les
connaissances par rapport à l'amiante
était parfaitement établie et ce depuis
le début du siècle dernier et l'état
français n'a pas pris les bonnes mesures
au bon moment et ça a trop duré jusqu'au
début de l'année quatre vingt dix sept
une nouvelle action judiciaire plutôt
bien acceptée par les ex salariés prêts
et a plus grand chose à faire pour être
reconnu mais je pense c'est la
possibilité oui et vous qu'est ce que
vous allez faire je vais continuer la
procédure avec maître chez lui vous
pensez que vous allez pouvoir obtenir
quelque chose je l'espère est le plus
rapidement possible mais les années sont
comptés depuis l'ouverture de ce dossier
il y a cinq ans douze salariés d'alstom
sont décédés suite à leur exposition à
l'amiante